justin trudeau voulait marquer le coup
un grand coup nous allons être
carboneutre d'ici 2050 assure-t-il il
reste toutefois très vague sur la
manière d'y arriver
un gouvernement libéral réélu mandatera
un groupe d'experts pour lui tracer la
voie
ils s'engagent aussi à couper moitié le
taux d'imposition pour les entreprises
de technologies propres
on a au canada le talent la vision et la
réputation d'être le meilleur endroit au
monde pour démarrer et faire croître une
entreprise de technologies propres
malgré ses ambitions le bilan
environnemental du gouvernement trudeau
en est déçu plusieurs comment on peut
croire maintenant qu'un gouvernement qui
a acheté nos lits duc va maintenant dire
qu'on va avoir des cibles progressistes
c'est pas acceptable c'est pas possible
il faut que justin trudeau arrête d'être
schizophrène
on va pas sauver l'environnement en
investissant dans le pétrole ses rivaux
lui reprochent aussi de ne pas avoir
éliminé les subventions à l'industrie
pétrolière comme il l'avait promis il
rappelle que les mesures actuelles pour
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre comme la taxe sur le carbone ne
permettront pas au canada d'atteindre
ses cibles cible qui avait été établi un
gouvernement un peu elle proposait les
plans avec aucun détail écrit ce n'est
qu'ainsi le coin de table
les conservateurs accusent les libéraux
d'être trop vague
le chef adjoint chez eux critiquent
aussi dès qu'il le peut la taxe libéral
sur le carbone son tacle sur la coban ne
fonctionne pas on recule
avec le plan de justin trudeau et la
cool la vie va augmenter à fier de faire
partie d'un pays qui s'engage pour
l'environnement
pour répondre aux attaques les libéraux
ont lancé une offensive publicitaire où
il mettre de l'avant leurs candidats
vedettes l'environnementaliste steven
guilbeault
le choix est très clair pour les
canadiens aller de l'avant avec ce
gouvernement libéral qui a démontré son
leadership et va continuer ou choisir un
gouvernement conservateur qui revient en
arrière
à trois jours de la marche sur le climat
montréal les libéraux veulent utiliser
l'environnement pour marquer un
contraste avec les conservateurs justin
trudeau promet d'ailleurs qu'il
annoncera d'autres mesures à ce sujet au
cours de la semaine
il siffle et vincent foisy radio canada
lundi